on a remarqué à peine depuis la rue une
maisonnette située dans la cour arrière
d'une autre résidence c'est
extraordinaire c'est la tranquillité
c'est juste la bonne grandeur pour un
couple Jean-Luc Gagnon et sa conjoint
ont acheté la propriété qui comprend les
deux maisons il y a environ 15 ans ils
ont d'abord habité dans la plus grande
située à l'avant puis ont décidé d'aller
vivre dans la petite on partage le
terrain eux ont de l'autre côté nous on
a gardé toute la luzière ici en avant la
cohabitation se passe bien avec leurs
voisins chacun à son intimité éliminé
les vues les fenêtres il y a pas de
fenêtres de ce côté là et on a aménagé
notre Patio dans une cour intérieure ici
pour le couple de Saint-Lambert c'est un
projet de retraite on voulait avoir
quelque chose de petit
réduire les coûts autant de chauffage
que les taxes municipales que
réduire l'entretien facile à mettre la
clé dans porte pour partir voyager ils
ont entièrement rénové et agrandi la
maisonnette qui a été construite en 1890
c'est donc en vertu d'un droit acquis
qu'ils peuvent rester ici parce que dans
la vaste majorité des villes du Québec
il est interdit ou pratiquement
impossible d'aménager ce qu'on appelle
des unités d'habitation accessoires
comme des maisons en arrière cours ou
des logements rattachés un bâtiment
existant ici on voit un garage pour le
rangement et juste à côté une porte
d'entrée pour unité d'habitation
accessoires mais ces logements existent
déjà sur le territoire québécois bien
souvent dans l'illégalité comme celui-ci
qui donne sur une ruelle de Montréal ça
se passe tout le radar et on croit qu'il
est grandementant de reconnaître le
phénomène et non seulement le
reconnaître mais le permettre et le
promouvoir selon lui avec la crise du
logement et leur désir de densification
les villes du Québec doivent emboîter le
pas à d'autres provinces ou les unités
d'habitation accessoires sont autorisées
on parle de l'Ontario la
Colombie-Britannique Vancouver Toronto
Ottawa qui ont des règlements des aides
aux citoyens des guides des conseillers
au Québec la ville de Sainte-Catherine
sur la Rive-Sud est l'une des pionnières
en la matière et la revue son règlement
sur les unités d'habitation accessoires
qui permettait uniquement l'aménagement
de maisons intergénérationnelle on
exigeait qu’une porte commune ou des
pièces communes entre les logements sur
10 ans on a eu 9 demandes de projets un
seul intérialisé conformément à la
réglementation donc c'était tellement
compliqué que les gens abandonnaient
leurs projets ou demander des
dérogations depuis janvier il est permis
d'ajouter un logement supplémentaire à
sa évidence ou de construire une maison
dans sa cour arrière et de la louer à
n'importe qui pas nécessairement à un
membre de la famille l'objectif de la
ville c'était d'avoir de permettre une
nouvelle forme de logement une nouvelle
forme d'accès à la propriété
là c'est justement pour cette raison car
rien duguez et sa mère ont déposé une
demande de permis afin de construire un
deuxième étage aux bungalow familial
avec le marché actuel des maisons
c'était difficile d'avoir accès à une
propriété la jeune femme pourra vivre
dans son propre logement tout en étant
près de ses parents on va avoir une
entrée commune ensuite chacun une porte
pour rentrer à la maison dans nos dans
nos appartements respectifs puis on
partagera la cour le stationnement puis
le garage et si jamais elle part ses
parents ne seront pas prises au
dépourvus ça sera possible de louer à
quelqu'un d'autre qui est pas de la
famille la Ville de Granby a mis en
place un règlement similaire il y a un
an pour la densification douce tout
d'abord mais aussi pour permettre une
meilleure accessibilité peut-être à des
logements à d'autres citoyens ça peut
servir comme revenu d'appoint pour
héberger un proche que ce soit un enfant
un parent ou quoi que ce soit avec son
nouveau code d'urbanisme Laval permet
maintenant d'ajouter un logement à la
maison unif familiale Longueuil lancera
un projet pilote sur les unités
d'habitation accessoires au cours de la
prochaine année ce type de logement sera
donc de plus en plus présent dans le
paysage